israel has been making swift progress in
its covet vaccination campaign
it currently has the highest vaccination
rate in the world
but that's only for its own population
and not for palestinians living in the
occupied west bank and the gaza strip
this week though the government bowed to
international criticism
and began immunizing palestinian
laborers who work
in israel dw's tanya kramer filed this
report
a vaccination center at an israeli
checkpoint between the west bank town of
bethlehem
and jerusalem here only palestinians
holding a permit to work in israel
or in settlements are vaccinated by
israeli authorities
as a young person and a palestinian
worker
i can take the vaccine but at the same
time i think of my father and mother who
didn't get it yet
i'll feel better when all my family
members have been vaccinated
israel aims to vaccinate about a hundred
thousand workers who cross over from the
occupied west bank to israel
every day the country has faced
criticism
abroad and at home for not providing
vaccines to more of the palestinian
population
israel's interest is clear in order to
open the economy and return to normal
we need everyone who is moving around
inside israeli borders to be vaccinated
and safe
but in the israeli-occupied west bank
ordinary people are still waiting for a
broader vaccination rollout
in ramallah nurse itaf has only a few
vials to administer to her fellow
medical colleagues
the modern vaccines were part of a
one-time delivery by israel
a small amount but still seen as a
relief for those having to deal closely
with patients
we as doctors and nurses are on the
front line i wish that everybody will
get vaccinated like this
so we will be protected and have the
capability to move on and fight the
disease
the palestinian authority says it has
procured vaccines from different
companies
but it has come under public criticism
for delays in delivery
in february 10 000 doses of the sputnik
vaccine arrived from the russian
government
vaccines through the kovacs program
providing vaccines for lower-income
countries
are also expected
the situation here is deteriorating in
palestine but also as in several
countries around the world
as a result of the late arrival of the
vaccines
the discrepancy in administering the
vaccines does not bode well
in bringing the end of the pandemic any
closer
about 2 000 doses of the sputnik
vaccines were sent from ramallah to the
hamas-controlled gaza strip after
israel approved a transfer the blockaded
territory also received about 60 000
vaccine doses from the united arab
emirates
for a population of 2 million and it's
crucial
infection rates in the west bank have
soared in recent weeks
in this private hospital on the
outskirts of ramallah
medical staff have seen a sharp influx
of serious covet 19
cases attributed to virus variants
until 15 days ago the corona award was
half empty and we were emptying the
department
suddenly huge numbers started coming to
the hospital
all of a sudden the hospital became full
full
restrictions were tightened once again
in the west bank recently
a curfew on weekends and at night was
already in place
to curb the pandemic while the wait for
more vaccines
continues